my name is Lauren my pronouns are she
and her thank you so much for being here
my talk is called why I chose to
modularize the ducks in my react app so
my journey to tech was rather
unconventional and non-traditional if
you will I didn't study computer science
in college but actually was an English
teacher for seven years before embarking
on my journey of learning to code during
those years in the classroom I spent a
great deal of time lecturing about
structure and by that I mean the five
paragraph essay the part of writing an
outline like really exciting stuff rules
of grammar proper sentence construction
essentially all things structure
organization when it comes to a high
school literature class so this all
combined with the fact that I'm also a
Virgo means that I really really really
like structure and specifically like
organized structure a Teta developers
academy a tuition-free program that
trains women and gender diverse filk to
learn to code in seattle washington hey
what's up baby yeah man my peers were
constantly giving me a hard time over my
color-coded notes but in my defense this
sort of stuff suits me you know it
brings me peace and joy and sanity and
while learning to code just like my old
classroom I loved when everything had
its place you know with code there's
always a right and a wrong way it either
compiles or it doesn't for example it
felt really satisfying when learning
Rails learning that the business logic
must go in the model or with react that
the render function can only return a
single function as a newbie I liked
learning about the parts within code
that have strict black and white
expectations of implementation you know
switching from humanities where I got to
talk about books and our feelings all
day to learning to code you know just
one year was overwhelming in itself
and so in search of something
comfortable and familiar
I found myself gravitating towards and
literally memorizing those rules
I love the clarity the concreteness you
know the structure of it all and
discovered that it was at least one area
during the wild and crazy' world that is
coding that I could actually excel and
thrive in and for those exact reasons I
for a long time now have idolized sandy
mats and simply loved how strict her
rules of practical object-oriented
design are I'm realizing I'm making
myself myself sound like really painting
a picture
I swear I'm fun I swear like I promise
anyhow when I joined my first software
engineering team after ADA it will come
to no one's surprise to learn that I was
like super overwhelmed by the massive
code bases that are so many companies
have you know there are hundreds upon
hundreds of connected systems for each
org with different teams using different
tools in different tech and yet somehow
they're all connected together working
with complex dependencies and oftentimes
for the sake of speed of production
little structure it felt like an
unfriendly web of connectivity and
interdependence that I didn't feel
confident and making sense of and my
first week task my manager sits me down
and says okay just make sense of the 13
code bases that we use daily today and
of course ropes all in the wound
he's like vividly recall him saying like
it's a no big deal it'll be fine
and like the interconnectivity of it all
it was a lot for me to take in right
like it felt like the wild wild west of
interdependencies in my rule and
structure loving self needed to take
some deep breaths shock right like get
overwhelmed easily you know but as he
did it is like all of us do right and
I'm sure we've all done before I tackled
the task just as I'm sure we what's up
phrase like how do you eat an elephant
one bite at a time which I like don't
get that phrase really like you know
okay right so okay all that to say is
I slowly did one file at a time and soon
I learned that our team was doing some
pretty cool stuff we were responsible
for aggregating and pulling user data
and code from over 20 different orgs and
databases to create a comprehensible
analyzed summarized most sold list each
week so the data we we it was aggregated
but it wasn't done perfectly and so each
week a p.m. on our team had to curate
and edit that top twenty titles list
before publication using a web app our
team had thrown together using a pretty
outdated and logic list templating
system called moustache Jas yeah
familiar I see nods and then in
combination with handlebars and because
this list curation process was so
incredibly cumbersome during my first
weeks on the job our team was tasked
with optimizing that app so the decision
was made for many reasons but the
biggest one being that the code was I
mean a complete hot mess of spaghetti
so now handlebars and in mustache are
not necessarily bad tools right as I
said though moustache is a logic list
mplet library it's perfect for bindings
simple data or an HTML template but
that's really it you know it's just too
simplistic for what we needed and while
simple can be good it's generally not
used to describe robust web applications
so what started out as a teeny tiny app
morphed into as I mentioned a spaghetti
code of a mess in just a few months my
team referred to it as kludge meaning
that it was a quick and dirty solution
that was clumsy and an inelegant and
inefficient difficult to extend and hard
to maintain do you want me to show you
it just for like the sake of awe oh
excuse me
with my technical difficulties this was
an interesting choice to just show you
for the sake of showing you but this is
the HTML file index.html file and it is
massive like I mean it is long you can
see over here on the viewfinder like it
goes for a while and it's like never has
a long file masa file like this done
well for us right in the world of
maintainability and scalability
it was difficult of modificated to make
modifications like look at this I mean
it goes anytime like the JavaScript
files are defined in here in one place
it makes it like reading a book
essentially but not knowing where the
chapters are or not knowing where any
like where you are in wood place so
anyway that's what that looked like and
we were pissed like we were ready to do
something different with it was
difficult to maintain or difficult to do
much with
oh there it is okay all right so as you
can imagine when I first open to that
codebase my type-a desiring structure
self was itching on the inside over at
all but I was lucky my manager agreed
and so instead of a refactor he
suggested a complete overhaul and we got
to start fresh from scratch we decided
to invest in the art of doing it right
for the first time so this encouraged us
to dive into the interwebs for research
you know we considered the frameworks
out there and decided to let our needs
guide us we knew that we required a
front-end framework that allowed us to
easily unconditionally show Dom elements
based on criteria build an interactive
client experience with many views and
many different levels of user access and
to easily consume multiple api's so we
came up with this list as they were the
requirements that had caused us a great
deal of difficulty and achieving them
had felt really burdensome and
complicated with moustache but after
doing some research we discovered that
we were in fact describing all things
that would be quite a breeze with the
JavaScript library any ideas react okay
so I had previously built an app using
react native and it wasn't just because
it was the hot tech at the time although
it certainly was but our research told
us that it would supply us with some
pretty cool capabilities and the aspects
that we were most excited about worm you
know the ability to render on the
virtual Dom reusability of the organized
components the fast learning curve
native compatibility lastly just like
innovative developer tools essentially
we were pumped about its promise of
speed and ease and capabilities and it
felt as though all signs are pointing us
towards react but maybe you're not as
easily convinced as we were let's pause
a moment and cover why react is so
awesome so by definition react as a
JavaScript library developed by Facebook
in 2011 for building user interfaces
it's the view layer of web applications
is in the view in the MVC the Model View
controller but this definition
and you know it doesn't really do it for
me right it's one of those sentences
that like I have to read over and over
in my head multiple times before I can
even come close to making sense of it so
instead let's break it down into
comprehensible pieces or components if
you will and yeah my first coding joke
okay so that's what react is really all
about components components are
essentially a piece of user interface so
when you're building an application with
react you build a bunch of independent
isolated and reusable components you
then compose them all together to build
complex user interfaces so every react
application has at least one component
which will refer to as the root
component one component represents the
entire application and contains other
child components so every react
application is essentially a tree of
components here's an example let's
imagine we want to build an application
say Twitter we can split that page into
components like the navbar profile
trends feeds and those are all the
different components and to represent
that in a tree we have app at the top
and below we have the navbar profile
trends feed and then the feed components
can include several tweet components and
each tweet can include like component
which we can then reuse on other pages
or even in different applications so as
you can see each component is in a peak
is a piece of the user interface we can
build the components in isolation and
then put them all together to build
complex UI's in terms of implementation
a component it's typically implemented
as a JavaScript class that has some
state and a render method the state here
is the data we want to display when the
component is rendered and the render
method is responsible for describing
what the UI should look like and the
output of the render method is just a
react element which is a simple plain
JavaScript object that maps to the Dom
element but it's not a real element it's
just a plain JavaScript object that
represents the Dom element in memory so
react keeps a lightweight representation
of the Dom in memory
which will refer to as the virtual DOM
and unlike the browser or the real Dom
this virtual Dom is cheap to create and
so when we change the state of a
component we get a new react element so
react will then compare this element and
its children with the previous one and
figure out what's changed and then it'll
update a part of the real Dom to keep it
in sync
oops with the virtual Dom so that means
that when building with react
unlike vanilla JavaScript or jQuery we
no longer have to work with Dom API is
in the browser in other words we no
longer have to write code that queries
or manipulates the Dom or attaches event
handlers to the Dom elements which is
awesome so we simply change to the state
of our components and the reacts will
automatically update the Dom to match
the state and that's exactly why this
library is called react because when the
state changes react essentially reacts
to state changes and updates the Dom
okay so this all sounded like dreamy to
us felt really awesome and again we were
stoked to give it a try but I should be
super clear because I've just spent a
good amount of time talking about all
the good things that are react there are
however a few drawbacks and I've you
ever miss if I didn't cover those so my
team realized pretty quickly that our
architecture true probably ended up
getting becoming a bit more complex than
the example I just showed us and that
we'd be passing state as props around
the app quite a bit now reality
advocates for a single directional flow
and things can get messy when we want to
keep our data in sync when two or more
components share that same data ideally
the source of truth of that data is only
in one place the react Doc's encourage
you to lift state up if you have two
children that need to access the same
data this means putting the data in the
nearest ancestor of the two components
but if the two components are very far
away from the tree the nearest ancestor
component could be at the top level of
the component tree to complicate things
even more the intermediate component may
have absolutely no usage for the
it's being passed it just happens to be
stuck in the middle and has to pass it
along
no thank you my favorite analogy for
this is the idea of me wanting to tell
my cousin a story but instead of being
able to tell her directly that story I
also need to tell my aunt now that's
fine if it's a little non embarrassing
story but say it's something I don't
necessarily want my aunt to know about
bummer dude
like I still have to pass it through her
regardless so the top ancestor has to
pass the data through several
intermediate components along the way to
get to the proper component and just
like the game telephone some of us may
have played as kids this creates a
million different opportunities for
developer air or in clarity for future
users the original story can get muddled
and someone could easily get confused as
they try to trace the props as they get
passed down between many components it
game no bueno so to view it another way
one state is being passed back and forth
and up and down between the component
trees it's easy to manage that things
could have complicated real quick and
add insult to injury my girl sandy Metz
taught me to always fear coupling and
that's happening like big time between
each component and its parent so to try
and move a component around become super
complicated because there's coupling
going on between the component and its
parent and then between the components
children that it's passing props to and
no one's surprise this impacts
performance because every update so the
data made will cause all the children to
re-render which can cause massive
performance and speed issues ok that's
where we were at we know the good we
know the bad of react and ultimately we
felt that the good definitely outweighed
those drawbacks but we knew that we need
to find a solution for managing our
application state if we were going to
build such complex applications we
wanted our application to scale you know
obviously we wanted it to be
maintainable for many months or years
right into the future and we knew that
we wanted to maintain our sanity when it
came to state management so that's when
we discovered Reed
it's the state container superhero that
saved our day yeah okay but like let's
chat about that right so Rita what is
redox how is it different or how does it
change react if you will or what
problems does it solve and ultimately
like why would someone say yes to the
dress
that is Redux you know okay so by
definition Redux is a state management
tool for JavaScript applications and
while it's frequently used with react
its framework agnostic meaning that like
it's compatible with many racks like
frameworks such as angular and ember
view even just plain JavaScript so learn
it once and you can use it with a whole
lot of things like a sales pitch person
okay I'm I don't work for react or Redux
but you know okay but I'll acknowledge
it right like again our definition here
it isn't working for me you know it's
not it doesn't tell me why or how it
solves Reax problems that I just
described let's go back remember the
chaos that was the mess of passing data
around the components that is what Redux
successfully helps us make sense of
so with Redux I can pass data or that
embarrassing story about my most recent
bumble dating escapade to my cousin
without also having to tell my aunt
about it as well they I get to avoid the
chaos are the story being bounced
between all of the components are like
all my crazy uncles and I just get to
update that one or change it right it's
this all becomes possible because of
Redux is most important principle which
is the universal storm so let's talk
about what that is as I said it's a
state management tool the big thing to
remember is that the state entire state
of application is stored in one central
location called the store I'm realizing
that really might look like a nipple my
bad my bad okay moving on meaning that
each component of your react app gets to
have direct access to the state of the
application without having to
props down to child components or using
callback functions to send back data to
a parent and that's pretty dreamy Redux
provides a central store that can hold
data from anywhere in the application
another analogy can be painted that with
just react on its own say you went to
the market and only wanted to buy an ice
cream cone but instead you'd have to buy
you know everything not only in the
desert aisle but the produce and deli as
well in react you don't get to be
selective of the data and how much is
passed on but in redux it you're allowed
to it allows for those individual
components to be connected to the store
and encourage its encouraging you to
extract just the pieces of the data that
each component actually needs as opposed
to all the data that exists so data no
longer is being passed down through
multiple levels of components you know
now code is simpler it's fewer
components are involved and rendering
performance is optimized these are all
good things
Plus because Redux also follows the
one-way directional flow all of the
logic in the app becomes more
predictable easy to understand for your
fellow teammates in the future so
because data is normalized you won't end
up with multiple independent copies of
the same data that are unaware of one
another all over the place to put it
differently Redux completely eliminates
the messy tunnelling that can happen
when you're passing data from a parent
down to many different subcomponents and
manipulating it all in those places okay
so we sold by my explanation at this
point my team was and Redux sounded
pretty during magical dreamy to us so
let's break down the basic steps of
implementing Redux before I do I want to
introduce these principles as I'm going
to refer back to them pretty often so
the first is that everything that
changes in the app is contained in a
single object called the state or the
state tree this makes it easy to create
Universal apps as the state from this
your server can be serialized and
hydrated into the client with no extra
coding effort next
it's important to know sorry that the
state of the app is only changed in by
pure functions which only return the
exact same output for the given input to
specify how the state tree will be
transformed
you'll compose pure functions called
reducers that take the previous state
and action and return the next day
instead of mutating the state the
previous state okay and lastly the only
way to change that state is to emit
actions which are objects described what
has happened subscribing what has
happened so this ensures that neither
the view nor the network callbacks will
ever write directly to the state instead
they express an intent to transform the
state now this is a diagram of how all
that happens I'd really love to lift the
veil on what truly is going on here and
makes sure that each step along the way
may just make sense and I'll do that by
utilizing a pretty straightforward
example application that example is a
react app that aggregates data and
showcases a list of the most binge TV
shows of 2018 I am a millennial after
all so you can imagine that each color
here is a different react component let
me show you what that code actually
looks like
this was the old one goodbye index.html
file like that one's gone okay cool
so this is the route app or route
component and it calls the other
components it calls first the new title
component that's the ability to add
something new and then a list view the
list view then calls the individual
component which then has further
metadata and it's broken up stored all
within the components really simple I'd
say it's running right here locally and
again like no Eve I didn't even add any
CSS into it I just wanted it to show it
for our example purposes which will be
to transfer it into a Redux state
organization system so currently our
with just react the data in this app
flows directionally downward like that
but as I just said I want to add Redux
so that the state and the data transfer
is going to look more like this so we
referring back to the Redux flow diagram
the first thing that we have to build is
the store so it's so crucial to remember
that in the store in Redux is it's just
like our human brain right it's
absolutely fundamental the state of the
whole application lives inside the store
so to start playing with redux we should
create a store for wrapping up the state
shall we do that altogether yeah yeah
let's do it let's build three tags okay
because it's not going slow toggling
between those two at all okay so here we
are actually before we do that we should
turn off our server and in fact let's
like I'll just start from the beginning
you'll run npm install redox and so
while that's happening let's go back to
our folder and in the source folder
we're gonna create a folder call we'll
start with just redux right and in redox
I said that we're going to start with
the store will create a
folder called start okay in there we'll
create a file called index dot JSON
ports for things that we actually a
relative one that we haven't built yet
but then we will write a function called
create store and it's going to call
reducer okay and then lastly we're going
to export defaults
okay awesome
so that's that's what we'll start with
create store is the function for
creating the redux store which you may
also pass in an initial state to create
store can I make this bigger for you all
sorry about that maybe most of the times
you don't have to do that though
although passing an initial state can be
useful for server-side rendering
traditionally the state comes from
reducers which is what I'll do here and
it takes a reducer for the first
argument roo-roo der Sar here in our
case well wait okay I'm sorry let me
back up because I haven't really
explained what reducers do yet so okay
and let's I let's let's go through
actually then what reducers are and how
crucial have a role that they play in
the world of redux so what our reducers
what do they do let's go back to our
diagram in Redux reducers provide the
state the state is not something that
you necessarily create by hand reducers
specify how the application state
changes remember one of the principles
of redux is that the state is immutable
and cannot change in place in plain
react the local state changes in place
with the function set state but in redux
you cannot do that a reducer is just a
JavaScript function and it takes two
parameters the current state and in
action which is why the reducer must be
pure and again pure functions are those
that return the exact same output for
the given input
and creating a producer is actually
pretty simple so let's do that all
together so in our in our Redux folder
right now we'll add another folder
called reducers yes that was pretty
quick transition and here we'll we want
it to reducers
okay and in there we'll add a new file
called indexes and and there we'll call
initial State and we're gonna pass in an
empty array go there and then we'll go
export default just as we should route
producer sick ok oh thank you thank you
so much ok anyway so this reducer is
sort of a silly one it returns the
initial state without doing anything
else but definitely notice how the
initial state is passed as a default
parameter so now let's go back here and
the reducer are without a doubt like the
most important concept in redox let me
say it again reducers produce
essentially the state of the application
but this then begs the question how does
the reducer know when to produce the
next state ok hopefully it looks like
that well that's where actions come in
one of the principles of redox is that
the only way you can change the state is
by sending a signal to the store this
signal is an action dispatching an
action is the process of sending out a
signal and how do you change in an
immutable state remember you don't so
the resulting state is a copy of the
current state plus the new data and you
may be thinking whoa Lauren that's a lot
of data to know but the reassuring thing
is that redox actions are nothing more
than JavaScript objects so this is an
example of
it might look like so we know the drill
let's create a simple action together
we'll create an action folder and index
dot JSP
in there a new file and in that we'll
add here okay so every action requires a
type property for describing how the
state should change and it's really just
a string that's this piece right here
and the reducer will use that string to
determine how to calculate the next
state and you can specify a payload as I
did if you'd like in my example the
payload is the new show so it's best
practice though to wrap everything up
those actions into action creators and
the reason we would do that yes there it
is okay and hopefully it looks something
like that which it did okay and so since
types are just strings and strings are
prone to typos and duplicates it's
better to have the action types declared
as constants so as I said it's best
practice to wrap every every action
within a function which definitely helps
to avoid errors that would be difficult
to debug so let's also do that quickly
and create a simple action creator again
I'm going to create a new folder
constants oh no for those of you that
were do not pay attention I just
konstanz oh look I can change it will
that work okay and here action types
okay Jas oh I could have called that
index as well anyhow we will export this
and then all we have to do is go back
over to our actions folder and what we
need to change here is delete the quote
marks here to actually pull it in but of
course we need to import it as well
so in portlet what's happening oh oh I'm
so sorry I have no idea how to fix that
right now but I'll figure it out for you
all it's so slow mo okay all right can
you hear see now all right sorry about
that my god so here you are where I just
created the actions where I created a
constants file and I have to delete this
one and I in here I added add show and
here I'm going I just deleted the quote
marks around these and I'm going to then
locally pull or do a relative file of an
import and so that's gonna look like ad
show from Constance and I think I call
the action types cool
so are you all still with me no okay
maybe yes yes okay so you know maybe
maybe it'd be helpful for us before we
go further just to recap really quickly
the main concepts and kind of things
that we learned and of course I'll wait
for a visual so that you can see that
because that's helpful this is the slide
I usually show and I ask you if you're
here like slow down okay so the redux
tour is in charge of orchestrating all
the moving parts all the state lives in
a single immutable object and as soon as
the store receives an object or an
action it triggers a reducer when the
reducer returns the state the order sort
of kind of looks like this an action
first occurs within a component such as
someone trying to add a show or a filter
view you know see the details even like
deleting a component then that calls the
action in action types which then grab
the particular reducer that will update
or modify the state and once the state
has changed the view is rendered into
that there you have it okay so our code
though we created one reducer and an
important refactor that should happen to
set up we need
kind of make the some changes there
because the reducer calculates the next
state depending on the action type and
it should return at least the initial
state in the case that no action type
matches anything so we'll do a really
fast refactor and change our reducer to
become a switch statement so doing that
can you all see that okay so here in our
reducer file we will change this to look
something like that
how does that look yeah cool actually I
set us up because it is valid code but
the above reducer breaks the main redox
principle immutability so if you look
here in this line you know array dot
prototype dot push is an impure function
it alters the original ret array you
know making our reducer compliant though
is super easy we can use concat because
that in its place of push and that's
enough and or enough to keep the initial
array immutable so what we'll do is we
will change this here to become let's
see stayed yeah and then we'll pass
shows state dot concat as opposed to
push action da payload cool we could
make it even better if we wanted to add
in a spread operator which would look
really good too but let's head back to
our PowerPoint so notice though that
when we were doing that that the initial
shows array doesn't change in place
remember that's super important the
initial state object doesn't change as
well the resulting state is a copy of
that initial state and then our redox
code looks like pretty bomb hopefully
well let's just double check that it
looked like that yeah okay cool I'm
convinced so hopefully it's not overkill
to be like alright we're familiar with
redox now-ish right we know the vocab
terms we know it's implementation let's
revisit really
we though the reasons one might choose
to add Redux on top of the reacts to
help manage their application state so
centralization her centralizing the
state makes it super easy to implement
things like logging changes to the data
or persisting data between page
refreshes and predictable state updates
makes it easy to understand how the data
flow of an application works and lastly
using those pure reducer functions makes
logic easy to test Anna enables useful
features like time travel debugging
essentially Redux is helpful in those
complicated yet common scenarios when
you have multiple components that are
not closely related to one another but
want to share all or the same data okay
so like all of you here we have learned
the basics and my teammates and I were
excited to begin creating an app with
reactant redox and work ready to be off
to the races without a care in the world
except you may have noticed that while
we were setting up our redox and I had
to keep going back and forth and it was
like pretty painful in the like addition
of all those additional folders and
files etc you know imagine adding all of
the functionality of a traditional app
right if you're gonna continue down this
path it's pretty easy to imagine how
things could get like crazy messy and
confusing really quickly so you'd have
to edit write like the constant starting
in one file and then edit the reducer in
another okay and then go there and then
you'd have to edit that actions in
another and then call to action creators
and get another file you know this means
that like even adding a really small
piece of functionality like requires you
to edit and manipulate and toggle
between a ton of different files so and
with this this like structure if you
will is is called by type and it's super
common it's yeah get out of here ok it's
organized by type as we just saw you end
up hopping back and forth between files
for
single piece of related functionality
because the constants actions and action
creators are imported into the reducer
file and the action creators are also
imported into the container to then be
dispatched and all of that kind of
becomes a little annoying when you agree
yeah ok here's what I found to be really
wild ok there is actually no prescribed
one way of organizing your Redux files
this by type method is super common and
is taught in like a ton of tutorials but
obviously it's sort of flawed right my
theory is that oftentimes like when
you're learning about Redux and the
roles of actions and reducers you start
off with really simple examples and most
tutorials available don't take you to
like the next level so if you're
building though something with Redux
that's more complicated than a to-do
list you've realized pretty quickly that
you may need a smarter way to scale your
codebase these actions and constants and
reducers are all related but in a
fractured State and honestly switching
from one file to the next only takes a
few seconds yes I get that but it makes
my head kind of fuzzy and it's like
really slows down my personal production
efficiency and honestly simply put it's
hard to maintain so thus yet again all
of my English teacher organizational
habits came rushing back to me and I
knew I knew what that there needed to be
a strategic and thoughtful way to
organize my code structure in
architecture and I dove into the
resource research and medium files and
articles knowing that there had to be
something out there that would offer me
some peace of mind
and I was right there are a lot of ideas
out there about it some people were
suggesting online that a solution to
this frustration might be to like
organize your code by feature as in
encapsulating a component the container
it's state the store and its behavior
the actions into a single folder all
following reacts component concepts but
this means that you'd have to tie a
slice of the redux store into a
container
and that is completely counterintuitive
to the core of what Redux promotes so I
was not about to adopt that pattern and
so back to the drawing board I went and
further research led me to ultimately
discovering tada the moment you've all
been waiting for it based on the title
of this talk Ducks to the rescue so what
are ducks though really quickly Eric
Rasmussen coined the terms when he
observed well okay Java has stars and
beans
ruby has gems I suggest we call Redux
bundlers ducks as then the last syllable
of redux
so he realized that he was building out
the rest he was building out Redux apps
that he was doing it in one piece of
functionality at a time he kept needing
to add action type actions reducer
tuples for each use case he kept he was
keeping these in separate files and
several folders it as I did however 95%
of the time it was only one reducer
action pair that ever needs its
associated actions thus it makes more
sense for these pieces to be bundled
together an isolated module that is
self-contained and can even be packaged
easily into a library so Ducks is
essentially a proposal for bundling
reducers action types and actions all
into the same file but why specifically
with the organization structure be this
why would that be a solution to our
problem or rather why get excited about
ducks like beyond their adorableness
factor that is right
so duck seeks to solve the issue of that
toggling back and forth repetitive
nature by organizing that you get when
you organize by type so with ducks
rather than splitting up all related
code we can package it into redux
modules ok that's enough talking I want
to show you how quickly how easy it is
to create that redux file
do your refactor all into one so ok we
just need to you can see my screen yes
yes you can
and one last folder one last file let's
call our redux sometimes I call it
modules but like let's get a little
crazy let's live a little
let's call it what it is it's a duck so
here we are the first thing that we're
gonna do is grab from our action types
from our constants file so over here I'm
gonna grab that and I'm gonna go back to
my folder and I'm going to mmm write an
export statement check for my typos here
because I'm gonna try and go fast add
show is going to be set to boom okay
sick now the deleting and this is the
really fun part gets to begin we are
going to go ahead and just delete that
first folder that we created
goodbye constants C and ever okay now
we'll do the actions and in this folder
we will grab all that back in our in our
index we will write another export
statement pop that in there and then see
I action folder never again
yep I said that okay now reducers but
let's just grab it all you know let's go
crazy grab that piece from there and
then plop that oh you know what don't
get too excited we have to add an expert
flat file alright BAM oh it's redox
sorry wait our redox it's duck stuff
that's it oh wait no I'm not done
because I didn't ever do all right check
it out like suck it redox like that is
all now just in one file is maybe that's
not as exciting for you but I would like
I love love love love the ease of that I
mean right like it's it's little it's
small but it's this idea that
the like it feels like it's a
modularized it's creating this that's
really what the Ducks looks like so
hopefully our code looks a little like
that yeah I think it did almost on it
yes live coding for the win we did it we
made our Ducks so it's pretty I find
this to be pretty incredible because
Ducks sing is a way of structuring an
app to become more modular like yes
that's a really sexy buzzword in the
world of software engineering right but
like honestly it is really this is great
because it becomes obvious what piece of
redux is handling what functionality and
on a completely practical level you no
longer have to scroll through masses of
files before finding you know the one
you need to work on and in theory it
would be pretty straightforward to
switch out redux for any other state
management library if the need ever
arose because those files are completely
separate from the react or ssin of the
app but this is only one way of
restructuring of structuring your redox
you know there's plenty of others out
there and the simple fact that I'm
standing up here encouraging you all to
explore ways to creatively define what
you know might work for you and your
team means that maybe that structure
obsessed self or that type a person that
was like you know maybe she's leveling
up and becoming that software engineer
that it like seeks to define her own
rules and doing whatever is best for
your code and your team ultimately maybe
that's the right choice you know what I
love about Docs is how clean and clear
it is it removes a lot of unnecessary
boilerplate and you can easily then add
an action or a field to the reducer by
changing it in a single file you know
best we were convinced and maybe you all
are too to really bring things home I
thought it'd be interesting to show you
my team's more developed Redux file that
has a ton of other functionality in it
you know it has the ability to add to
the to the database which is what we all
walk through but this one now also has
reducers to retrieve all of the data
from the API edit the data I
and then see The Associated titles and
and filter it all in one view and then
here we have really a snazzy switch
statement
so my team ultimately we've really liked
the ease of that and I think this is
ultimately like really just the
beginning of where things can go right
this is one way of structuring things
there's so much in the world of react
and redux to explore and that can be
things like web pack or react router I
have those on a slide really fast or
Ria's for the Middle where you know it's
just I've had an incredible learning
experience for me hopefully you got
something out of me sharing this all
with you today as well I really hope
that some of you are walking away from
this talk feeling is so maybe react
maybe Redux aren't so confusing or scary
anymore and maybe you were convinced by
the Ducks model of organization I I
think it's so fun and this in this world
of react Redux all the different things
that we can be doing this hot reloading
really just a whole host of other
technologies out there for you to
explore so you know go forth have fun
play and maybe try out the Ducks
modularization
I don't know thanks so much for
listening though my name is Lauren and
I'd love to chat further if you have any
other like kawaki questions let me know
I'll be around here's some resources for
you if you're interested
probably this is the original this is
the recipe original github repo so if
you're interested in learning about duck
specifically check that out
thanks guys